was it something you didn't expect in
terms of preparation you were like I
couldn't imagine the amount of work it
actually was when you first started it
was set to Joy like every minute of it
was such a joy that I think I I did
tougher movies that were like you know
low budget in the winter in Toronto cold
and like you know no you know what I
mean like doing nights like like that's
hard right The Matrix of course it was
so much work but we had so much support
um which I had never had before so we
have you know you have your trainer and
you have somebody making your food and
you've got a driver and you know Keanu
and I became very close to that process
he was very supportive and Lawrence was
super supportive and Hugo we had this
family relationship that supported us so
um I never think of it like oh my God
that was hard like
I I would go to work even when I didn't
work just to watch because I didn't want
to miss any of it you know because I was
like I've been watching Keanu or
Lawrence or Hugo practicing that fight
for four months I gotta go see it I
gotta see what it looks like um I mean
and this was pre being married and
pre-happing children you know I can't
really do that anymore because
um you know I'll do it occasionally if
there's something that I really want to
see but in general I don't really I
don't go to work anymore